the world economic Forum are a huge
Global Network of elitists the super
rich and they have a world agenda which
they themselves announced and said that
their goal is that we all own nothing
and be happy about it in this video I'm
going to be talking about that this is
something that many people have talked
about and are unsure about but the
reason I'm talking about this today is
because I recently attempted to become a
member of the world economic Forum it
cost half a million pounds a year to
join the network and guess what I got
half a million pounds so I reached out
to them and I said hey I got half a
million pounds I want to be a member of
your network and they would not have me
as a member made me think why not so not
only do you have to be really stinking
Rich I've never felt so poor when I
applied to be a member of the world
economic Forum which literally have got
people they're all associated with all
the politicians and Mark Zuckerberg Bill
Gates all these folks are all in this
network and I'm like well I'm rich now I
want to join I want to help save the
planet I want to make the world a better
place which is what you guys all want
that's what that whole thing is about
let me join and they said they gave me a
little checklist and they said what is
your net worth is it between
a million and a billion
is it between a billion and 10 billion
is it between 10 billion and 100 billion
I was like damn I'm right at the bottom
of the food chain but listen I can still
afford your 500 000 pound a year
membership and I am among two
millionaire my net Worth's 20 million at
least so come on let me in and they
didn't even respond and I've been trying
to become a member and they haven't
responded so I did some investigation
into who they are and what their agenda
is and the results were shocking and I
think it's almost verging on evil so I'm
going to talk about my factual findings
and then let you decide
foreign
[Music]
economic Forum said that their agenda is
that we will own nothing and we will be
happy the only optimistic way to look at
this is that everything will become
subscription based and we will not need
to own things and that is why we will be
happy about it for example I don't own
any DVDs anymore either own CDs I don't
own things like that because it's now
not essential because the world has
moved on with its agenda now we have
subscriptions such as Netflix such as
Spotify they're also definitely seems to
be an agenda that instead of owning
houses that we now rent again our whole
life is rented and leased on a
subscription basis our cars we're being
incentivized to use public transport and
to go electric into lease cars so the
world is moving away from owning what
you have and Leasing and renting what
you have now while that may not sound
like a bad thing and it's okay to lease
everything it's the way of the world the
scary part of that is that if everything
is leased by these big tech companies
what happens if they don't like us what
happens if we step out of line and they
decide to cancel us on a individual
level like they did with the Russians
where they just said no more Netflix
they don't have DVDs if they cut off the
supply of what you're leasing what it
does is it gives them complete control
and complete power and most of these
people in these groups are billionaires
or multi-billionaires and it almost
seems to me like when money is No Object
anymore the next high is world power and
control and domination that's a scary
thought
interesting that Prince Charles is a
member the Chinese president is a member
the banks are a member there's massive
World banks that are members of the
world economic forum and they're telling
us to stop buying houses to not own
things they're desensitivizing the the
ability to even own a property yet what
are they doing what are the banks doing
well we know that the Lloyd's bank right
now in the UK BlackRock what are they
all doing they're buying houses on mass
and then they are renting them out to us
so when they say oh nothing and be happy
really what I think they're saying is
you will own nothing and be happy and we
will own everything and be even happy
they're calling this the great reset and
people are celebrating the great reset
because they're broke because they don't
own things and they're saying yeah let's
just let the government and the rich
just reset everything and the great
reset sounds like a good idea I'm sorry
but to me the great reset sounds like a
horrible idea in fact anything that's
ever started with the great in history
has always ended in destruction the
Great Depression the Great Leap Forward
the Great Recession the Great War
whenever anything starts with the great
and as a world agenda behind it it has
always ended in destruction and
Devastation for the general public but
what about all the celebrities though
that are endorsing it what about all the
big A-list celebrities that are standing
behind the movement and saying yes this
is wonderful this is going to help the
world well you know what whenever the
celebrities are all endorsing anything
at the same time you know what I
generally do run and the way that we are
evolved to live becomes more and more
distant and remote we don't live as
tribes we're not in control of Our Own
own resources the idea that we will own
nothing and we will be happy sounds like
a terrifying not orwellian but sort of
huxilian idea that we will be sonared
into compliance drugged by a sort of a
magical substance in our water into dumb
compliance with the objectives of the
powerful while we live as kind of human
drones the world economic Forum
currently has 3 000 paying members and
with membership costing around 500 000
pounds the question is where does that
money go and nobody knows where that
money goes and the truth is is probably
to fund the government and the media
have you ever noticed how the media and
the government all seem to sing off the
same song sheet and agree at the same
time with the same things and usually
the agenda is to bash the rich and tell
you don't try and build a business don't
worry we'll look after you
the agenda is to weaken men and break
down families and if you step out of
line or say something they don't like
they will literally de-platform you you
can just suddenly overnight be banished
off of Instagram off of YouTube off of
everywhere and not have a voice anymore
no debate no discussion just canceled
gone interesting and I'm having to be
extremely careful about what I say on
this video this video risks being
de-platformed maybe I'll end up Suddenly
off of YouTube as well but I just
couldn't bring myself to not speak at
least based off of the research that
I've done and share my opinions on this
matter they train world leaders via
their young Global leader program even
Putin was trained by them the world
economic Forum recently said that
capitalism needs a dose of Marxism no
capitalism does not need a dose of
Marxism Marxism has devastated
everything's ever touched just look back
at history wake up and the irony is so
shocking the fact that the royal family
are members of the world economic forum
and then the world economic Forum are
telling us to own nothing when they
literally own so much can we not see the
irony so what are the world economic
Forum actually doing apart from trying
to get us used to the idea of owning
nothing what are they doing with their
billions of pounds that they already
amazing through the world economic Forum
where there's no trace of where the
membership money actually goes well it
would appear to me that what they're
doing is they are controlling the media
so that people don't think for
themselves anymore you will vote how
they want you to vote they are trying to
gain complete control of everything and
everybody and stripping financial
literacy from people keeping them dumb
so they are slaves and workers what
should they be doing well in my opinion
I'm all for the idea of a world economic
Forum I'm all for an idea of wealthy
people getting together how to make the
world a better place and change the
planet but what they should be doing is
they should be bringing financial
literacy into schools they should be
championing and incentivizing businesses
giving to charity they should stop
taxing the hell out of small struggling
businesses relying on the government for
you to be looked after always ends in
poverty and Devastation we need to be
relying on ourselves and being
entrepreneurially minded and building
businesses and even though they're
trying to discourage us buying
properties with tax incentives to not
with legislation with tenant eviction
bans scrapping section 21. you know what
I think I think that now is the time to
step forward and start owning as much
land as we freaking possibly can right
now while we have the opportunity to buy
land because it's very difficult for
them to take it off us that's what
they're trying to discourage us from
doing it in the first instance so my
advice is to buy as much land and
property as you possibly can and to
build wealth in such a way that is
sustainable and adaptable right now in
2022 and I don't want to bring a message
of negativity and doom to you right now
through YouTube so the question is what
should you do as an independent person
as an entrepreneur how are some of the
ways that you can react to and deal with
this world plan to stop this happening
because that is exactly what we will do
well firstly I would say stop blindly
following celebrities opinions because
they are often paid by these people to
share their opinions have critical
thinking from the media and do not be
blinded as a sheep do not be sold the
lies of the government about looking
after you financially it is a trap
become financially independent and share
the message far and wide for all to see
now I have a saying that says if you can
change it change it and if you can't
shut up and that's why I've resisted
putting out a video like this for so
long so I just want to share three
things that I am doing to actively help
with the situation and the economy
firstly is I am bringing Financial
education to people so that they do not
have to rely on jobs I'm bringing
financial literacy to schools by giving
my time voluntary to go out and to speak
in schools and to teach kids how to be
financially literate to teach kids how
to understand the difference between
good debt and bad debt assets and
liabilities passive income and active
income I'm building schools across other
parts of the world we just built a
school in Uganda and the government have
agreed that because we paid for the
building that we can have a say in the
school curriculum so that the kids can
be financially literate and I am
speaking truth in spite of fear so this
video May well get banned so share the
heck out of it get educated and get
buying lands and properties now so that
later on you are not relying on these
psychopath Elites to pay your rent
[Music]